there are growing concerns around the
globe over the growing gap between
wealthy and poor not just in the united
states of course but literally around
the globe and there seems to be a
consensus emerging at least in some
quarters over some sort of wealth tax in
the united states for example taxing
some of the wealthiest americans in
order to help pay for things that the
government is currently not paying for
is that such a good idea joining us is
gary stevenson he is a traitor turned
inequality a comment economist he joins
us from london
gary first of all before we get into a
wealth tax explain why is wealth
inequality continuing to get worse
i think it's very important that people
realize just how much wealth inequality
has increased in the last two years so
during covert there has been a truly
enormous increase in wealth inequality
and um i think this happens in a way
which is a little bit counterintuitive
and i think it's very important people
understand because the first thing is
the government
gave out an enormous amount of money
during code four trillion dollars that's
truly enormous it's about fifteen
thousand dollars for every adult in the
country
um
now in many cases that went directly to
people who are poor and in need so i
think people might think this would
perhaps be good for inequality but you
need to take it in a broader context of
what's happened during coving so during
kobe there was a cancellation of a lot
of spending but not all spending okay if
you're a poor ordinary person and most
of your spending is on rent mortgage
food bills
those expenditures remained during
coving the kind of expenditures which
disappeared during kobe were luxury and
non-essential spending so who has the
most luxury and non-essential spending
basically it's rich people so during
covid rich people massively stopped
spending now that causes two problems
one is that spending drives ordinary
people's wages
the other is
if they don't spend it then it starts to
accumulate in their bank account so when
the government came in and basically
supported the incomes of ordinary people
they didn't do anything about the
massive amount of money accumulating
rich people's bank accounts so
essentially the government has taken the
place of the rich and money which used
to flow around in a circle has now
flowed in a line from the government
to ordinary people and ended up
accumulating rich people's bank account
so the end result is four trillion
dollars accumulating in the bank outs of
the rich that's fifteen thousand dollars
for every american adult if you out
there do not have fifteen thousand
dollars more than you had before covered
some rich person has got it
now some of those rich people obviously
are getting wealthier not because of
productivity but because their value of
their papers is going up but what about
the argument that some
very wealthy people who create a very
good product or who are very productive
with their industries are benefiting
because of that productivity listen i've
got nothing against rich people okay i'm
a rich person myself i've made a lot of
money by betting that inequality would
destroy your country's economy so listen
i'm the best person to ask okay i've got
nothing against rich people i've got a
lot of money and i've made a lot of
money during coving but the problem is
if you give the rich people four
trillion dollars and you know i really
cannot label enough how much money four
trillion dollars is like if i was to
come to you three years ago and say
imagine the government that's printed
four trillion dollars and gave it to
rich people what would you say would
happen well if you just said that to me
i would say well probably it will push
prices up and it will cause the cost of
living crisis for the people who didn't
get the four trillion dollars and you
know i'm not just saying that now people
can go and look at the videos i put out
on my youtube two years ago saying look
the government is printing huge amounts
of money it's going to rich people and
it's going to cause inequality to rise
house prices to rise stock prices to
rise and the cost of living crisis of
inflation for ordinary people that is
what happens if the government gives
four trillion dollars to rich people so
look i've got nothing against rich
people i don't hate them you know what i
mean i've worked with a lot of them some
of them are even quite nice if you get
to know them but the truth is this is
the cause of the cost of living crisis
and it's meaning that ordinary americans
can't feed their kids what could the
government have done differently though
during the pandemic if the goal was okay
let's help people who are struggling
have lost their job i mean i suppose it
could have been some sort of means
testing in a way but there was some sort
of means testing towards focusing this
money on people who direly needed it
listen 100 give the money yeah you have
to give the money every country in the
world did that because you have to do it
but if you are gonna print four trillion
dollars and give it out you need to do
some back of the packet calculations
and say look who is going to end up with
this money where is this 4 trillion is
going to go you can't give out 4
trillion without doing some analysis of
where the money is ending up because all
the statistics now show that that
money's ending up with the richest
people in the country
so the problem the problem was not look
the problem wasn't this wasn't helping
people with the money it's that it
wasn't accompanied by not only analysis
of where the money went out but also
then some means of getting the revenue
back from the wealthiest people who were
seeing their wealth grow even more yeah
i think there just has to be a little
bit of understanding which is look this
is an emergency situation we need to
give money out but it is going to cause
a transfer of 4 trillion of wealth from
the government to the richest and that
is going to cause an economic crisis you
know
you know this analysis should have been
done at the beginning and then we should
say okay
well the rich are going to get four
trillion dollars we will need to get
some of that back otherwise we will
cause this sort of crisis you know the
set and i know it was an emergency
situation but the analysis was missing
four trillion dollars has transferred
from the us government to the wealthiest
people in the country it is the largest
and quickest ever increase in wealth
inequality in the united states you know
if you are going to have the largest and
quickest ever increase in wealth
inequality then that will be associated
with the largest and quickest ever
decrease in living standards for
ordinary people and increasing living
standards for the rich this is not
rocket science and my biggest concern my
biggest concern is that right now this
cost of living crisis gets blamed 100 on
vladimir putin and russia because i can
you can see happening in the media now
and if that happens then it means that
this four trillion dollars which is
still sitting in the bank accounts of
the richest americans by the way will be
left there and they will use that to buy
houses that your kids need to buy stocks
and shares that you need for your
pension to drive up wealth inequality to
even higher levels
we will see an economic disaster and we
are seeing it one of the efforts to try
to rectify part of the solution has been
in the united states that senator
elizabeth warren has proposed a wealth
tax uh the the rap against that is that
it would not only tax you know the
wealthiest one percent but you would
have some very wealthy doctors and
businessmen and people who aren't so
wealthy would also be pinched and have
less money that they would spend and
circulate in the economy thoughts
yeah look i'm a strong campaigner for
world tax i've been supporting it for a
long time and what i always say when
people say this is look i'm not about
taxing people with one million dollars
okay i'm about taxing people with 100
million dollars okay the average
billionaire in the us has seen their
wealth double in the last two years
during a crisis in which increasingly
ordinary people can't afford to heat
their homes okay
these guys if you allow these guys to
take more and more wealth they will use
that to buy the rest of the homes you
know i'm not just saying this i've been
betting on this for 15 years and i've
made millions of pounds doing it okay if
you allow these guys to accumulate more
and more wealth they will eventually
take everything and you will see an
economic disaster and we are seeing it
so um
look if you're out there and you're a
doctor or a lawyer you are not my enemy
you know what i mean i was a banker
myself you know i've got money you know
and i'm willing to pay a bit more but
the problem here is the super super
what about the problem that some people
have identified like bernie sanders has
identified people essentially trading
pieces of paper so he wants to put a
a a transaction tax or a penny per trade
on wall street with the idea being that
okay the financial sector in the united
states you shouldn't be able to make so
much money by trading so quickly with
speculation and making bats that there
should be some sort of tax on that does
that make sense in your estimation well
listen i've traded a few pieces of paper
in my time so i guess some people be
putting some fingers at me here look
the most important thing with any tax is
that it hits the riches it has to hit
the richest okay look if you if you're
not going out there and you're getting
if you're not getting jeff bezos and
elon musk then you are failing in your
tap so look i would be willing to
anticipate to talk about lots of
potential taxes that we could do the
most important thing is that you catch
the richest you have the cat because i
know people out there will be looking
we'll be looking at me and saying you're
going to bring a taxi and the richest
will avoid it and you're going to hit me
that's not what i want to do i want to
bring a tax that is well designed well
planned and hit the richest people in
the country
you mentioned and you've been correct on
a lot of things like inflation on the
wealth transfer on all the sort of side
effects housing prices going up uh given
your track record let's ask you a little
bit about the future what do you see if
nothing changes what do you see
happening over the next year or two in
the united states with the economy
david i'm not going to sugarcoat this
for you this is going to be a disaster
this is genuinely going to be a disaster
i'm sorry but look look what's happening
already now okay they're increasingly
people can't afford to defeat their
families all right winter's going to
come and half the country is going to be
struggling to heat their homes that's
what's going to happen and then you've
got another 23 above that that have an
extra 2 3 000 extra cost of living
well that's the money they needed to go
to the shops to go on holiday to go to
bars to go to the cinema to go to the
theater right these guys can't go out
anymore you know this money that is
being sucked out of ordinary people's
purchasing power that is the money that
drives the economy
and you see
and you see inflation continuing at the
current pace i mean a lot of economists
think well inflation will probably taper
down by the end of the year how do you
see it
inflation will eventually normalize but
the point i want to make is even if
inflation normalizes that doesn't mean
prices go back to where they were so we
will move to a new normal where the
normal cost of living is permanently
higher relative to an ordinary person's
wages and that means the standard of
living will be permanently lower for
ordinary people and this is exactly what
you should expect when you have an
enormous and permanent increase in
wealth inequality this has been the
largest ever transferred world from
ordinary people to the rich so ordinary
people will see the quality of life full
if they don't change that do you see a
connection between that wealth transfer
and we've done some stories on this
particular program about for example the
uh the companies that are responsible
for for food and grocery prices whether
it's the grocery stores or the uh the
the tyson chickens uh that their prices
have gone up far faster than the cost of
living
far higher than even inflation so it
seems like within certain sectors in
america there's a lot of corporate price
gouging that's going on
listen rich people have much much much
much more money than they had two three
years ago
fifteen thousand dollars per american
adult has been printed and it's all
ended up with the richest which means
the average wealthy american family is
sitting on hundreds of thousands even
millions of dollars cash more these guys
are going to buy more stuff and they can
pay more with it and partially they'll
invest in natural resources
they can buy and hold those natural
resources to make themselves richer look
if you make the rich much much much
richer then they will take a bigger
share of the output and of the natural
resources that leaves less for the rest
of us
gary if you could have a conversation
with joe biden and top members of
congress right now what what would you
say to them what's the what's the
solution here assuming that they have
the political will and the votes to do
it what's the solution
listen
you guys have presided over the biggest
and fastest ever increase in wealth
inequality
but it's fixable the money is there that
four trillion dollars is sitting in the
bank account of the richest americans
while ordinary people are struggling to
heat their homes and feed their families
four trillion dollars is there you have
to access it be careful plan the tax
that works but you have to tax the
richest it's the only way to avoid an
economic disaster here and finally gary
how did you go from being a trader to
being somebody who was essentially an
advocate for for this kind of work oh
well i don't have much time but um
uh yeah i'm from east london near the
financial center i went to the london
school of economics and um actually
before the financial crisis citibank
used to hire one trader a year through a
card game which is basically a matter
game um i'm good at maths i'm good at
games i entered that and i won and uh
yeah i became a trader in them i was
quite a good one if people want to know
more they can check out my youtube
gary's economics lots of information
there okay
gary stevenson he's a trader turn
inequality economist gary good of you to
join us uh thanks for being with us we
appreciate it thank you